wir schauen ins café nobis denn dort an
dem tisch die kanzlerin eben gerade noch
mit armin laschet saß das ist jetzt
unsere kollegin annika rasch
alica wie schmeckt der kaffee im café du
bist was hat die kanzlerin und armin
laschet gehört zu sich genommen was
haben sie vielleicht gesprochenes wie
geht es dort jetzt vor ort überhaupt den
besitzer der so wurden besuch an diesem
samstagmorgen empfangen dürfte
genau das café ist ungefähr 200 meter
entfernt von der bühne auf der
gegengerade nach angela merkel und amina
stadt gesehen habe und ich setze mich
hier mal kurz an den tisch auf dem platz
von angela merkel neben mir sitzt herr
resende
filialleiter heute hier und jetzt auf
dem platz von angela stender was haben
die beiden dann eben gerade gegessen und
getrunken werden haben gar nicht
vergessen wir haben nur jeder ein
espresso in großen kräfte und schlüsse
gezogen
und wie lange saßen die beiden hier 20
minuten und dann ging es los zur bühne
und wie ist das so für sie wenn er
plötzlich denn die kanzlerin in den
laden kommt und der vielleicht bald
kanzler wie war das herr laschet ist
öfters bei uns nur straße dann sehen wir
auch das schon mal frau merkel war dass
ich noch nie bei uns im café aber es war
auch sehr kurzfristig kurz vorher kam
einer von der cdu und hatte gefragt ob
man hier frühstücken könnte und dann
haben wir das möglich gemacht und sie
waren ja wahrscheinlich auch hinterm
tresen kommen sie dann trotzdem beim
bedienen vielleicht irgendwelche
wortfetzen auffangen worüber die beiden
geredet haben sie in letzter minute
ich leider gar nicht sie haben leider
geflüstert und
wert am ende bezahlt frau merkel oder
herr laschet und die sekretärin von frau
merkel hat gezeigt das trinkgeld und
anleitet wartet schon öfter bei ihnen zu
gast oder kunde bei uns im café ware
keinen kunden einige sagte ist öfters
mal einer straße im blick aber hier bei
uns war und jetzt als letzte frage
einmal wie war ihr eindruck von armin
laschet glauben sie er kann kanzler
ich denke dass er das schon kann
ist sehr freundlich sehr höflich aber
ich denke auch es fehlt vielleicht ein
bisschen an
dass man den interessieren bisschen
stolz als aachener dass der nächste
kanzler vielleicht aus der eigenen stadt
kommen kennt und da schon natürlich klar
ich will natürlich waren auch sich
also wie ihr hört es gab kaffee espresso
und wasser die beiden haben auf essen
verzichtet aber saßen eben vor der rede
hier nochmal so 15 bis 20 minuten zu
einem gemeinsamen gespräch ja danke an
die kanaren ich wirklich doch bitten das
bild das trinkgeld auf den tisch legt
wenn es von der kanzlerin und armin
laschet da kein trinkgeld gehabt im café
also ich würde sagen dass gebe jetzt
einmal nach aachen weiter das geht auf
die bild rechnung wir gehen mal zeit wir
wollen noch mal nach aachen café nobis
hatte ich gelernt dorthin also gehen wir
an den tisch noch mal an dem gerade die
kanzlerin saß und armin laschet saß in
diesem historischen moment so wenige
stunden vor dem wahlkampf finale ja vor
der entscheidenden wahl morgen und
annika ich hoffe du hast den betrag
aufgerundet
genau wie aufgerundet die beiden haben
20 euro 10 gezahlt haben kein trinkgeld
dagelassen die sekretärin von angela
merkel bis 15 euro auf den tisch gelegt
hier ist jetzt auf dem platz von amina
saß ich dann auch auf dem platz von frau
merkel und habe mir jetzt auch noch
einen espresso sozusagen ein laster ist
presse geholt und genau stärken ich
jetzt auch damit und wie gesagt bild hat
die rechnung jetzt gezahlt
[Musik]